[Music]
diablo 4 is a love letter to our fans
we've really focused on this theme of
returning to darkness and we know that
when we make a diablo game fans have a
lot of expectations from d2r and diablo
3 and previous diablo experiences that
they've enjoyed so we know that we have
a lot of things that that really just
need to be there but also bring them
into the most modern versions of
themselves hi i'm joe shelley game
director for diablo 4. and i'm ron
ferguson the general manager of the
entire diablo franchise and we're here
today at blizzard entertainment hanging
out and we're going to talk about diablo
4 and
the whole franchise
diablo 4 is really all about choice and
it really manifests in all different
aspects of the game one of the things in
the previous diablo games you worked
with iconics and so there was this like
oh you're this barbarian that's known
from the history or the lore of the game
and now with the player customization
you create your barbarian you don't you
can choose what they look like what
gender
hair
makeup all the stuff that you want to do
to really truly make it your barbarian
and so you can kind of create your own
backstory and then from that you're in
and choosing your skills and that you
can choose very different skills that uh
you know and that really make it your
own work sort of like diablo 3 which is
great but it sort of tied a lot of what
you did to your gear so if you want to
change your abilities you just change
what you had equipped and that's not the
case in d4 that i mean obviously gear is
still very important to your build but
it's really about your your skill
selection that defines you and then you
take those choices into the game the
game the story is non-linear so you can
choose how to play out the story you're
in a shared open world you can choose to
go exploring instead of doing the story
if you want to you can go anywhere you
want uh within sanctuary and go do
dungeons or go do other things and take
on a world boss or a local event so you
have choice there and then you have pve
versus pvp so do you want to go and take
on the story you know campaign content
or do you want to go and fight other
players in one of our sort of pvp areas
and then who do you want to play with is
a choice right you can play so it's a
great game solo but you can party up
everything along the way is really about
what you decide you want to do and so
that's what why we talk about d4s about
choice is because pretty much every step
along the process there's some things
that you have agency over and you can
decide how you want to play the game
all of the classes in diablo 4 have this
sort of unique feature that's unique to
just that class and the necromancer is
the book of the dead where you decide oh
i can have skeleton warriors what kind
of skeleton wars do i want do i want
aggressive defensive do i ones that
create corpses for me to use as sort of
raw materials and then oh you can have
mages okay what kind of mages do i want
to use and oh i can have gollum what
kind of golem do i want to use and so
you can mix and match your warriors your
mages and your golem to really create
and customize the army that you have
with you and you never really had that
experience before
and that's what really is one of the
things that makes the new necro really
unique and interesting i like to talk
about diablo 4 being the culmination of
the franchise because it wants to
respect the past like there's and so
when you look at
kind of what goes into diablo 4 i like
to use the formula that it feels like
it's the dark tone of diablo 1.
it's the progression of diablo ii it's
the the visceral combat of diablo iii
and then it has
its own unique innovations in diablo 4
with the shared open world and all the
things we talked about with player
choice i think there are ways there are
lots of ways that we've looked at
lessons learned from previous games too
you know one of the great innovations we
made with legendary items and again
speaking to that idea of having multiple
builds available is that you can take
legendary power off
an item and move it to
another item so it really opens up the
ability to customize your gear we don't
talk about that enough you know in
previous thing games like you would pick
up a shield that have this thing that
would make i can now summon two more
skeleton mages and you're like oh i have
to keep this for as long as pop my build
knees those two extra mages and
eventually your level would outpace it
and you're like
like i don't want to give up the shield
i'm going to carry this shield even
though it's weak because i want this
ability and now in diablo 4 you can
actually extract that off the shield get
a new legendary that's at your level and
put that onto it and so that idea of
being able to hold on to your build and
be able to truly customize your
character by taking legendary powers and
distracting them from one thing and
imbuing them into another that
fundamentally changes the build system
so one of the things that's really
exciting about diablo 4 is that because
we have the shared open world that
exists as a template the dungeons are
actually in places in the world that
you're going to explore and those to
give those gives those dungeons a real
sense of um of place
so when you go into a particular dungeon
you're going to see
the tile set that's associated with that
dungeon that that type of art we have a
wide variety of
art
for these
and you're also going to see the
monsters that live in it but when the
dungeon
rolls
it is randomly generated within those
parameters the monsters will be
differently configured you're going to
see different champions you're going to
see different affixes
and you're going to see a different
layout for that dungeon on top of that
each dungeon has a dungeon objective
so when you go in you might have an
objective to slay a boss but you might
have an objective to
track down three fallen idols and
disable them and so the completion
objective for the dungeon uh is is
unique to each dungeon as well and one
of the things i really like when we play
is that you go in and you don't know the
objective like there's not some magical
person at the door telling you by the
way the reason how you complete this is
like you have to go in and discover the
objective which is really fun and the
dungeons actually play really well into
our end game right where you now not
only do you have the dungeons that
you're doing when you're playing through
the campaign regularly for say new gear
or a particular thing but
at the end all of a sudden you have
nightmare dungeons where did you want to
talk a little bit about like the sigils
and that you can upgrade the dungeons
with these sigils to make them nightmare
dungeons and they become more dangerous
additional affixes are applied to them
that make the monsters more dangerous or
can even um give you advantages
um and when you're uh getting these
sigils you'll get a wide variety of
sigils with all kinds of different
affixes on them so there's once again
player choice in which sigils you want
to do and if you get a sigil that uh is
for a dungeon that you know is not as
you don't think is well suited to your
class you just skip that one in two
different ones nightmare dungeons is
sort of our take on riffs and so if
you've played the previous diablo 3
there would be there's you know a thing
in town and you just go to it and opens
a portal and off you go and you're
standing in town
going to it over and over
and now we have these nightmare dungeons
which is kind of like running a rift in
a way but it has a sense of place so now
you have keys and so joe has sigils i
have sigils we're like okay where do we
want to go like we have to go somewhere
now and like okay let's mount up get on
our horses and we're going to ride west
and because that dungeon has a
particular type of loot that we want to
have our type of gear that we want to
get
and so i love that feeling of place and
not just grabbing a portal in town every
time we know that
it's fun to build your character and
discover all these powerful builds
and we also think it's really important
to have content to test that test
yourself against so we've really tried
to expand the
the variety of activities and you know
as rod said the the game um you know
when you finish the campaign you might
be level 45 or something your character
level goes up to 100 through uh through
paragon points and you get access to uh
to whispers you get access to nightmare
dungeons
other endgame activities that that we're
still working on
we really wanted you to have a wide
variety of things to do and of course
you've got
you've got world tiers that are allowing
you to step up the keep have make sure
that the difficulty of the world stays
on pace with the power of your character
level
and to unlock those um you actually need
to
uh to prove to complete a dungeon to to
access that more difficult content so it
goes back to the idea of making a build
making it powerful and then testing
yourself against some challenge and the
and the paragon point like so a paragon
system if you play d3 you know the
paragon system in diablo 3 but it was
just basically sliders and on a couple
of different aspects of your character
in diablo 4 paragon is an actual board
that think of it as a
checker board it's much more granular
than that but for simplicity sake i'll
say a checkerboard and you have to
navigate your way by sort of unlocking
squares as you move across the board and
each of those squares is could be plus
five strength or a different ability or
something that enhances your skills and
so you're able to click these different
boards together and make your own path
through so that's one of the things we
really like about diablo 4 is that even
if joe and i both were creating a
barbarian and even if we both want to be
whirlwind barbarians as an example
we can still have completely different
builds and and that's what really makes
i think diablo 4 unique is that we're
not ending up at the same place you know
there's a lot of games that when you're
done
everybody's the same and that's not the
case in d4
and so i think people are going to love
the new paragon system that idea is so
much more richer than we've ever had
before as a paragon system um and it
really when you see what it can do to
your character you really want to find
that optimal path across the board and
then when you go to connect the next
board you can actually rotate it to pick
the path you want to go through like
it's a really cool system there are also
glyphs that you can socket into the
board and you can upgrade those by
completing nightmare dungeons so there's
really a lot of diversity available
within the bills themselves and because
diablo 4 as a live service we'll be
continuing to balance the game so that
we can make sure that there are always a
variety of builds that are viable and
you're not focused into only one
there's a lot that we're looking at
doing for the for post launch like we
have a lot of plans when you think about
what um in terms of seasons but not the
way that seasons are for diablo 3
there's a sort of a twist on that um and
we do want to continue to expand the
world and tell new stories and continue
to tell stories
that are happening within sanctuary so i
think people are going to be really
excited about
you know what kinds of content and
features and things they'll be able to
do post-launch because that's one of the
things we really learned a lot i think a
lesson from diablo 3 is that we've had
you know like i said we've had great
success with the seasons in diablo 3.
we're still millions of players come
back and play for hunting hundreds of
millions of hours but uh we know that
they want more and that's what i really
feel great about what you know so much
diablo is coming now is that we're
actually able to sort of help satiate
some of the fan desires and what they're
really gonna get a deal before is not
only a great launch but a very rich post
launch all right joe thanks for hanging
out talking about d4 in the franchise um
that's it from us so i hope you stay
tuned we have lots of stuff to talk
about coming up especially you know more
d4
[Music]
you